SPEAKER: As enterprises
digitally transform themselves,
networks are at the foundation.
While networks are
constantly modified
to support business
applications,
you need a single
pane of glass that
can address all aspects of
troubleshooting and monitoring
so that complex connectivity
and network performance
issues are easier to diagnose.
Network Intelligence Center
is Google Cloud's framework
for network monitoring across
the cloud and on premise.
It improves user experience,
security, and operations
by providing a comprehensive
platform for monitoring,
visualizing, and troubleshooting
network health across the cloud
and data center.
Network Topology is a module
in Network Intelligence Center
that helps you visualize your
network so that you can monitor
your network health easily.
We have heard from customers
that visualizing cloud
topologies is not trivial, as
the cloud network is really
a mesh.
Everything talks
to everything else.
Imagine 1,000 instances
talking among themselves.
There is also a difference
between an on prem and cloud
environment, and it's
challenging to navigate
and understand the differences.
And customers want
to ensure that there
is no gap between tribal
knowledge of their deployment
and reality.
So our goal is to
allow you to navigate
the visualization
of your network
with structure and insights
so that network monitoring
and troubleshooting
becomes easier for you.
You save time, and in many
cases avoid network issues
altogether.
Let's start by seeing
a visualization
of your project, which is your
current deployment within GCP.
On the top, you can see
all the external clients.
We have traffic going to three
geographic regions here--
Americas, EMEA, and APAC.
You can drill down
into any of these
and see which specific
countries the traffic is
coming from or being served to.
In the middle, you
have load balancers.
Again, you can drill in and
see all the different load
balancers deployed.
On the bottom here, you
have your GCE instances
and the regions that
they're deployed in.
You can drill down to
the specific VM instance
level as needed.
Many customers want to
use this to quickly verify
certain policies.
For instance, let's
say you have a policy
in which all the traffic should
be going through the load
balancers.
You can click on the GCE region
or an external geo region
to see all the traffic
and verify the policy.
Here you can see that there
is some traffic going directly
from a GCE instance
to the internet.
Another example of a common
use case for customers
is to proactively verify if
the traffic is being served out
of the optimal region.
For instance, here you can
see that the APAC clients
are being predominantly served
out of the Asia East region.
This would help you troubleshoot
performance issues that
may happen as a result of
traffic being served out
of a non-optimal region.
You would be able to easily
see which regions the traffic
is being served out of.
You can also see the
evolution of topology
by going back in
time by clicking
on this timeline on the bottom.
This is very useful
in several scenarios.
For instance, if a
network event happened
and you want to troubleshoot
it, you can look at the topology
around the event
using this capability
to determine any
topology changes you
may have contributed
to the network issue.
During migration it
helps you to monitor
the state of your deployment
as you migrate your workloads,
thus providing better visibility
into your migration process
and also letting you
track it by looking
at the topology
evolution through time.
For troubleshooting, the search
capability is very helpful.
For instance, if you wanted to
search for a specific instance
and see what all it was talking
to or a specific load balancer,
you can do all those kinds of
search using this capability.
That way you can drill
down into exactly what
you're searching for.
All edges in the
visualization have metrics
associated with them.
You can click on any edge and
view how the metric changed
over a period of time.
You can see throughput in these
metrics, ingress and egress
byte counts, and others for
monitoring your network health.
If you have VPC
Flow Logs available
and you want to drill
in more to analyze
those logs, to
make it simple, we
show you the query to
the actual flow logs that
contributed to this traffic.
You can click on this link,
which will create the query
and show you the flow logs.
You could also use some of
these metrics for optimizations.
For instance, I am only
looking at the regions here
and how you could do certain
optimizations by understanding
what's contributing to egress
traffic across regions.
Here I'm looking at traffic from
US Central 1 to Europe West 1.
And lastly, you can also
look at your topology
at the organization level
to get an overview of all
your projects.
You can see how your projects
are talking to each other
and verify that it
meets your intent.
Congratulations.
You're all set up to start
using the network topology
module and Network
Intelligence Center
to visualize, monitor, and
troubleshoot your network.
[MUSIC PLAYING]